Does the RN deserve your vote next June?
Many political opponents point out that we see them very
little in the European Parliament,
thus assuming the general feeling in the face of 1 presence that
has 1 ghostly zy in the committees,
where the real work the egitative is done with 0 presidency or vice-presidency
of committee at the active time,
the RN euros deputies seem to play 1 solo score in 1 orchestra,
which does not hear them.
Accused of not working,
he retaliates by denouncing 1 cordon sanitary,
the insulation of key stations.
..
But is it a valid excuse or a confession of impotence?
At the heart of the debates,
the RN votes drew a clear line of distrust of the texts on LGBT rights,
the environment or immigration,
rejecting 60% of the proposals.
1 choice that requires 1 question.
Is this party really seeking to improve the place or is it
rather seeking to mark its ideal territory Logical?
At the same time,
Jean-Paul Gareau,
a figure of the party in parliament,
gave back the figure of almonds deposited as a trophy,
arguing that they were very active and not very visible.
But in a parliament where effectiveness is measured in
the ratio adopted and in the past law,
these amendments seem to be sword strokes in the water.
Support for Russia further exposes the RN to criticism,
their absence at the time of the tributes to the Crimean victims being
perceived not only as 1 lack of compassion,
but as 1 acidic alliance with Putin.
And let's not forget also that they had refused to condemn
Les of imprisonment of the opponent Alexina Vallni.
How to defend European values while sitting down in the face of adversity?
However,
far from emicycles and commissions,
the RN Excel in 1 arena where the fight is just as strategic,
that of the media.
..
With hundreds of relaxed speeches on YouTube,
the party deploys an impressive media strike force,
proving that if the art of legislative combat perhaps escapes them,
that of communication is mastered to perfection.
One thing is certain,
in the complex dance of European politics,
knowing how to stand out is not enough.
Still,
points need to be scored.